una nueva crisis energética en Cuba el
presidente cubano Miguel díaz-canel
informó a los ciudadanos sobre el estado
crítico en el que se encuentran las
reservas de combustible para el normal
desarrollo de la vida diaria en la isla
el mandatario enrutó el problema los
países con los que tienen contrato para
el suministro al tiempo que destacó la
complejidad internacional que vive la
comercialización de carburantes Y eso ha
llevado a propiciado ha ocasionado que
de un consumo entre quinientas y 600
toneladas diarias de gasolina
que el país
consume diariamente en estos momentos
estamos con coberturas de menos de
cuatrocientas toneladas diarias de
gasolina para todas las actividades del
país de manera diaria por estos días se
ha hecho como un observar largas filas
de automóviles que pueden durar días a
la espera de poder abastecerse a esto se
suman los graves problemas de
funcionamiento de las plantas
generadoras de energía debido a su
obsolescencia hemos tenido que depender
más de la generación eléctrica de la
generación eléctrica por la generación
distribuida que consumen lo fundamental
diésel por lo tanto una parte importante
del diésel que hemos dispuesto se ha ido
en generación eléctrica y por lo tanto
el país la economía sobre todo para el
transporte para otras actividades ha
dispuesto de menos combustible diésel en
este sector es donde más se ha visto
reflejada la falta de combustible debido
a que el transporte público es
ampliamente utilizado por los cubanos
en la parada para venir para el trabajo
ocho y media de la mañana hay veces que
llegamos hay veces que Llegamos temprano
depende de cómo esté la parada la falta
de un plan económico efectivo por parte
del gobierno el impacto del embargo
económico financiero y comercial de
Estados Unidos combinado con la crisis
económica internacional hizo que Cuba
entrara en una de las etapas más fuertes
de su historia solo comparable con el
llamado periodo especial de la década
del 90